tu es prêt de 27 heures de débats en
séance publique le groupe démocrate se
réjouit de voter en faveur de ce projet
de loi relatif à l'accélération des
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires et au
fonctionnement des installations
existantes notre ligne de conduite sur
ce texte et rester la même depuis le
début de son examen l'accélération des
procédures partout où cela est possible
et sans jamais rogner sur nos exigences
en termes de concertation et surtout en
termes de sûreté nous rappelions lors de
la discussion générale sur ce texte que
le groupe démocrate partage les deux
objectifs de sobriété et de
décarbonation de notre économie pour les
réussir le nucléaire est indispensable
il est d'autant plus dans la situation
géopolitique internationale actuelle qui
nous rappelle chaque jour un peu plus le
besoin de criant de souveraineté en
premier lieu énergétique
à ce titre comment ne pas évoquer les
dernières analyses du GIEC rendu public
hier sur le réchauffement climatique les
conclusions sont les suivantes il
confirment que pour limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degrés l'humanité
doit atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 en objectif partagé par la France
mais surtout le GIEC conclut qu'une
action climatique urgente peut assurer
un avenir vivable pour tous pour cela
les choix qui seront faits au cours des
prochaines années joueront un rôle
crucial dans la décision de notre avenir
et celui des générations futures
fort de ce constat scientifique la
volonté politique s'est exprimée de
manière cohérente depuis plusieurs
années à présent avec des ambitions
claires et sur ce sujet précis du
nucléaire le discours de Belfort du
président de la République il y a un an
à enclencher une réelle dynamique
l'ambition de construire six nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires avec l'objectif de
démarrer le premier en 2035 et le
lancement d'études pour 8pr 2
additionnels ce projet de loi vient
concrètement donner corps à cette
volonté politique s'il n'a pas pour
objet de déterminer les technologies des
futurs réacteurs ni leur lieu
d'implantation ce texte a un rôle
essentiel en ce sens qu'il agit sur la
réduction des délais de construction des
réacteurs via l'accélération des phases
administratives des projets
cela passe par la simplification de la
mise en conformité des documents locaux
d'urbanisme ou encore par des mesures de
sécurisation de l'accès aux fonciers ces
mesures concrètes présentes dans ce
texte auront des effets sur les délais
de mise en service des réacteurs et en
conséquence sur le coup des futurs
nouveaux réacteurs de notre pays notre
Assemblée a largement contribué à
l'enrichissement de ce texte notamment
avec des mesures accélérant la mise en
compatibilité des documents d'urbanisme
mais également en simplifiant la
délivrance de l'autorisation
environnementale ainsi qu'en
reconnaissant la raison d'intérêt public
majeur pour certains réacteurs nous
avons également renforcé le rôle de
notre Parlement avec la création d'une
délégation parlementaire au nucléose
civil et le renforcement du suivi
parlementaire des travaux menés par
l'ASN sur ce dernier point l'avenir de
cette autorité c'est largement invité
dans nos débats à l'occasion du projet
de rapprochement des compétences de
l'URSS au sein de la SN
le groupe démocrate n'a pas voté en
faveur de cette démarche au stade de la
Commission et cela pour deux raisons
principales sur la forme cette annonce a
surpris et n'a pas permis d'étudier dans
des conditions qui nous semblaient
adapter ce sujet et sur le fond nous
étions vigilants quand on rapprochement
des missions d'expertise et de décision
au sein d'une même entité si la
commission des affaires économiques
s'était positionnée en faveur de cette
fusion une majorité des députés en a
décidé autrement au stade de la séance
publique en inscrivant dans la loi la
séparation de deux autorités avec d'une
part les missions de recherche et
d'expertise et d'autre part celle de
contrôle et de décision nous prenons
acte de ce vote pour conclure ce texte
ne sera vraisemblablement pas l'unique
occasion de parler du développement du
nucléaire cette année puisque nous avons
à la révision de la programmation
plurielle de l'énergie qui intervient
cet été mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que c'est une un signal fort envoyé à la
filière du nucléaire en France puisqu'il
écrit notre volonté de retrouver à la
fois l'outil et la culture industrielle
nécessaire à la réussite de grands
projets nucléaires il s'agit de lancer
le chantier industriel de ce siècle pour
cela il est nécessaire d'avoir un cap
une vision une détermination claire le
groupe démocratie est engagé et votre a
bien entendu en faveur de ce projet